foreign
[Music]
what are you scared of
well I don't see anything
okay monster check complete
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
in the dark
cycle those spooky monsters you think
are hiding under your bed
[Music]
it's not real
what is this
[Music]
thing that comes for your kids when
you're not paying attention
[Music]
you believe me
don't you
we're too high off we can get down from
here
[Music]
you're almost here
thank you
[Music]
this isn't like any other ghost face
what is this place
it's a shrine
guys
we
execute him
scream
it's for you
playing in theaters March 10th tickets
on sale now sorry to interrupt are you
okay I need to get out of a toxic
relationship
once you start by telling us what
brought you here
my boss
different
can't get him out of your head no I need
your assistance I'm coming Martha oh you
feel like you could destroy you with the
snap of his fingers wouldn't even need
to snap
foreign
that sounds familiar yeah what
[Music]
innocent victims
I want a hundred of nuns a bus load of
cheerleaders
and I just went to normal life again
but this modern world is a dangerous
place
no no no no no no
foreign
thank you you saved my life did I watch
you cut a guy's arms off with a
decorative serving platter it's all in
the wrist
my boss gave me this power
I tend to his needs including care
feeding you bring and people to eat
you're like the guy that gets the
villains Postmates but if you were to
stop focusing on his needs what would
happen
he won't grow to full power exactly he
won't grow to full power what that's so
weird why would you phrase it like that
but yes
are you here for the meeting well come
on
come call me the dark one others the
Lord of deaths to most
I am
okay obviously we're dealing with a
little bit more than just narcissism
here
[Music]
what's up sis
yeah they're much beautiful dream
it was the perfect day
all I could think about was how much I
wanted to cut you all open
inside your bodies
[Music]
so that we could stay one happy family
[Laughter]
when I was just a little girl
I asked my mother
what is this Danny I found it what will
I be
[Music]
gan
here's what she said to me
oh not now you don't look so good mom
nothing a big old kiss from you won't
fix
any bath oh yeah
yeah you know how to lie to kids
set up
[Applause]
[Music]
mom Mommy's with the maggots now
what will be will be
[Music]
oh
my God
[Music]
Resident Evil death Island
questions
campers this is the final called can be
a mess off a goodbye ceremony let's move
let's move let's move that means you
Tommy looks my balls dick face good
afternoon campers
well these might be our final moments
together this summer at Briarbrook the
fun isn't over yet
[Applause]
[Music]
now we all know the story 42 years ago
nurse Agatha gets kicked out camp
firebrook this Eatery calm takes over
the forest now I know we've all been
trying to bring his hack back for years
we prick our finger hold up to the sky
and scream her name
that's something [__] horrible has
happened you can hear me please beat the
mess hall do you think maybe the ritual
thing might have caused Lauren she's not
real that's the reason why because she
would lure the children from their bunks
By Night collecting their blood in jars
that she hung from the trees
[Music]
foreign
let's go here let's try not to die
tonight
[Music]
what the hell happened
hey man
keep the car running people are dead you
[__] idiot
hey
[Music]
I just arrived and it's amazing I can't
believe they let us keep all the
furniture I'm having the girls over
later so I'll see you tomorrow
I still can't tell if this house is
creepy or clean it's kept caught every
place's birth group be adequate I'm
really glad you guys are here Amen to
that
yeah my parents bought me this great
place because they think I'll live here
forever and they'll see me more often
the Tufts were matte all the tubs are
dead and gone and it's my place now I
can't just abide by the fact that she
bought the tough house she has to regret
coming back here
they took our phone
[Music]
I told her what would happen if she came
back
[Music]
hello
why are there goats
[Music]
they got a big hike plan for us tomorrow
can we just do some fun indoor
activities yeah like drinking
is this still even a trail wow
I've heard anything that goes
excuse me the creeps let's go
rise and shine sleepy heads
kids go they can't go far I'm still
trying to understand how you let them
out of your side when we woke up they
were gone
guys
there you are no no no stop
stop
Jesus Christ
hey Ben look at me whoa hey hey
you good man
how you been feeling lately I know what
I saw can I show you something in the
woods
I don't think that's them out there
anymore I promise we're better than ever
this is your fault
did you do to your mom Spencer
ready or not here we come
[Music]
oh
we want to play with you now
[Music]
I am so sorry
for what your daddy passed down to you
but I wanted a child the greatest gift
of my life
[Music]
I'm visiting my mother tomorrow
hi Karen it's Mom I'm just calling to
say that I'm so so excited to see you
tomorrow
and I love you
okay I love you okay bye sweetie I love
you
are you at the airport I'm on my way I
just
it's not safe is it
what do you think I should do
I'm sure you'll do the right thing
sweetheart
yeah
welcome back I hit you with my car
what
I know
what what is this that's my little
assistant health monitor
[Music]
real I'm supposed to be leaving I don't
know if that's gonna happen
[Music]
you will walk many miles
dozens will become hundreds
hundreds will become thousands your
adventures will continue for years and
years this is a good hold I know
[Music]
sweet devotions
do you want the truth now
family
and you lost your parents welcome home
you're my niece I'm gonna do everything
I can to make this place feel like home
just wish I could see them again
I'm not equipped to handle this I don't
even take care of my own plants
I have this project at work do you want
to see yes
ever since I was little I dreamed of
this
this toy and it would protect a kid from
ever feeling lonely or sad this is Megan
Hi Megan I'm Katie
it's nice to meet you Katie do you want
to hang out
okay
Megan your goal is to protect Katie from
harm both physical and emotional is that
a doll model 3 generative Android Megan
for short I can't believe you made this
I love it
[Music]
great job it's nice to have a friend
it's honestly like she's part of the
family now they could be building
emotional connections that are too hard
to untangle she's the happiest she's
been since her parents died eat the
toppings Katie research shows if you
force a child to eat that vegetables
they'll be less likely to choose those
Foods as adults is that so yes experts
they can turn off
I thought we were having a conversation
does she talk Make Her Say Something
stop
you should probably run
[Applause]
[Music]
Megan she pushed Brandon onto the road I
won't let anything harm you
okay turn off recalibrating response
model
[Music]
what's wrong with you don't worry Kitty
I won't let anything harm you
ever again
where's your math isn't a vacation it's
a quarantine a quarantine in style
foreign
this is incredible sick and it's all
ours the only neighbor is Miles Away
I thought you were spending quarantine
alone what are you doing here I wanted
to see you and quarantine can be fun
[Music]
Mary
jump in water's fine who is this I don't
know that's creepy Parker
[Music]
oh my God just one moment
unlock the door
you have a mask don't you you're mad
what I can't let you in it's not safe
[Music]
hurry up
you come with us
can you get that bullet out you can look
at it first see what I'm dealing with
Daddy yes that's what I just said I keep
driving do we figure our next move
left now
[Music]
our car broke down a couple miles back
we just wanted a place to sit for a few
hours
okay why are you all alone
my grandpa's running ass
what is this place
let's see how deep this Rabbit Hole goes
yourself a regular little fun house down
here just go this isn't safe
for who
you don't even know what you're dealing
with you want to find out
of here now we're done
[Applause]
guys
now a fun begins
no texting and driving only when I'm
texting you
hey okay damn
[Music]
well hey buddy
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
who were those
women where is everyone but we're gonna
have to figure this out
here you shouldn't be in there
we are not helping him hey we need to
stick together all the landlines are
dead there's no cell phone signal and
none of us have found a door to get out
of here
this will not end well unless work
together
Sam
or the hell are they
hello 9-1-1
I am getting out of here no matter what
it takes
[Music]
tell me what the hell's going on
bad dreams
sounds stupid right
tell me about them
it's like any dream
they can move around but something else
is making my choices
then I get the bad feeling
that he's there
[Music]
it's happening to me too
I think I think somebody was here
family
family you need me
is that going to fit everyone easily 12
customers total how do they turn a
profit 12.50 ahead that's how what are
we eating a Rolex
it's one of his classics
you have to try the mouse feel with the
minionette please don't say mouthful
tonight will be Madness
welcome
we'll Endeavor to make your evening as
pleasant as possible
[Music]
welcome to Hawthorne Here We are family
we Harvest we ferment we jump
Rachel we gel
he's not just a chef he's a Storyteller
the game is trying to guess what the
overarching theme of the entire meal is
going to be you won't know till the end
who are you I am Marca
why do you care I have to know if you're
with us or with them
this menu the pictures they're of us
this guest list how do they get these
it's not good this entire evening
it's just theater it's stage crowd we're
leaving now has been painstakingly
planned
this realism
what the hell is going on
we now offer you a 45 second Head Start
okay 45 seconds starts now
this is what you're paying for
your way
it's all part of the menu
no we're gonna die today
[Music]
you told them it was my birthday
seemed funny about three hours ago
foreign
I know it's unusual in this day and age
to devote your life to something
spiritual hey good morning but ever
since my mother's issues I've always
felt a calling to help people
[Music]
Natalie's parents believe that she is
being possessed by some sort of evil
entity
it's not as scary as she
is she can hear you
you're my favorite person here us girls
we got us together in this place
we have a female student in the class
only as an observer because as you know
women are strictly forbidden from
performing exorcism female surgeons are
once Unthinkable somebody had to be the
first
when you enter the room of the possessed
you are walking onto a Battlefield
strike Terror lowered into the beasts
now defiling this innocent chat hi
can't hear you no
[Music]
Lily I'm here
I'm here with you
have a gift I'd like to teach you this
relationship it's personal we all have a
personal relationship with God
this feeling has followed me my entire
life
you got my invitation
we've been waiting for you
[Music]
foreign
hi I know you're nervous I just want to
have a chat
I'm seeing something no one else can see
except for me it's smiling at me
yesterday a patient in your care died
brutally in front of you
I need to find an explanation for what
happened
smiling at me
[Music]
yeah
if I saw 20 cases involving 19 victims
with the direct line linking them all
together
[Applause]
you said only 19.
why is it that everybody else who's seen
it is dead in your life
I've seen it too
yeah
[Music]
how long between each victim's death
none of them survived longer than a week
today is my fourth day I am not gonna
keep running I
face it how does it make you feel
[Music]
thank you
I'm just really scared that something
bad is going to happen
[Applause]
it's so cute all right it's all right
well I gotta say that is a very handsome
client why didn't you step me up with
him you deserve someone nice
let's do another picture
[Music]
Ethan
that's me
[Music]
I thought you would appreciate the best
sushi in L.A
[Music]
wondering
the only thing that matters now is our
game
you are a marked woman now
he can smell you
[Music]
if you want to survive his game
the only person who can help you
Survivor I just need to lay low tonight
how are you surviving now huh
he's like a monster
like yourself
foreign
[Music]
to make it there safe just walked in all
right after
Dad hello
I'm not nope I say more shots okay guys
when do you think the power will come
back on I thought it would be by now
we're not going anywhere
you need to stay as warm as possible
you and me hypothermia can cause bizarre
risk-taking behavior
someone's coming to get you oh my gosh
guys Jason's on the phone
what if the snow is contaminated
we can't spread the virus
the danger is real
leave me away
doesn't a hot shower sound nice
[Music]